freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
folge ein tag persönlicher koch heute
mit dem lieben holle die heute bei mir
zu gast ist ich war überrascht was du
dir gewünscht hast es war kein döner
dabei ist da habe ich wirklich überlegt
da ihnen eigen gemacht dünner alter der
effekt ist ja überlegt und er meinte
machen eigentlich es gibt so viele leute
die einfach ihr leben darauf legen den
besten dünner zu machen du hast die alle
schon gegessen und ich soll das jetzt
schnell schnell schnell hinbekommen
hätte ich niemals geschafft deshalb bin
ich froh dass du dir sowas hier
gewünscht hast super gesundes frühstück
ich mache den frischen saft dazu gibt es
ein schönes geröstetes brot mit avocado
granatapfel peter metz kopf ich glaube
dir nicht her gerne mal nicht von uns
jetzt
hat nicht wehgetan das ist super simpel
ich freue mich immer darüber wenn ich
einfach so etwas sinnvolles machen kann
weil hier entscheidet die qualität ich
habe wirklich das beste brot gehört dass
man hier in köln bekommen kann das
möchte ich vielleicht kurz anmache dann
so eine schöne filetierte avocado drauf
und damit fangen wir auch an bei den
saft machen wir frisch der kommen aus
der presse in das glas und kommt aus der
presse im grunde genommen kommen muss
hier raus bringen
ganz liebe zutaten wie gesagt kehrt dann
richtig bock drauf also granatapfel war
so eine der vorgaben die mir heute
frühstück gegeben hat und granatapfel
als folge sich wirklich selten gehabt
ich liebe es auch nur gerade weil ist
auch schon in der gehobenen gastronomie
auch ein paar machen weil das so
besonders ist wenn du weißt raubs platz
das ist einfach total geil und das jetzt
im frühstück unterzubringen wird richtig
schön find schneiden die avocado als
nächstes kümmern wir uns um unseren
granatapfel entlang der hecke schneiden
wir einmal ein und jetzt machen wir uns
eine schüssel mit wasser fertig also wie
man das unter wasser damit die spritze
hat vom granatapfel sonst nicht
erreichen der ellricher tage später den
abstand dann quasi so eine erste mal
habe man vom granatapfel kann man das
einfach unter wasser auslösen und wenn
man das über was warum
granatapfel kerne setzten sich unten ab
und das andere zeug schwimmt nach oben
also ist echt super praktisch ohne geht
das eigentlich gar nicht weil sonst
kannst du vergessen dann packen wir
jetzt unser brot ein weiter bot man
sieht schon
wie das aufgegangen ist
ordentlich olivenöl daran auch gut in
den tag startet ähnlich wie bei oma
gisela schritt genau also brot muss
einfach nicht angelastet werden soll
weil holt einfach nicht alles
ausgebootet aus wenn wir uns nicht geil
an rüstet das soll kein knusprig sein
dass man lecker sein und dann müssen wir
eigentlich nur noch beleben dann wollen
wir mal leute wir schnappen uns ein
angeröstet das brotbacken darauf
komplett ausgebreitet dann braucht man
auch keine butter kein frischkäse kann
nicht für avocados so fetthaltig packen
wir unsere avocado sagt da oben drüber
größen wir jetzt einfach ein bisschen es
geht nicht darum einfach so ein bisschen
würze rhein zu geben unsere väter und
danach ab gerne würde eigentlich nicht
so viel nehmen aber da wollen ein
richtiger fan von seiner tat bekehren
ist das
echt hübsch aus und gleich kommt ja doch
die krone
dass wir das
und dass somit stellen sagt mit sellerie
karotten ingwer apfel orange und
dann sind wir also ein frühstück steht
bereit man sieht hier richtig schön
zeigen wir von oben wie viele
verschiedene zutaten unserem was sagt
optisch sieht heftig aus die ja dass so
ein frühstück wie ich mir jeden tag
wünschen würde aber dafür zuvor waren
okay so gut dafür bin ich da eher
knistert ich bin gespannt wie du das
schaffst das zu essen ohne dass alles
auseinanderfällt das wird schwer das
wird schwerlich mit auch weggesteckt
nicht so begabt über mich von der bremer
gelacht weil ich so komisch und meinen
besteck hin und her auch aller härte
aber mit händen kennen rennt dann schön
dass wir bis dahin freut mich dass hier
dann
meine ich wirklich gute kommt das
nächste jahr begeht klaren aber so
einfach ziehen beide brot ist gleich die
sache generell probieren kannst einen
ersten eindruck mitteilen aber dann erst
wenn du alles fertig hast einen finale
bewertung sei also wenn ich hier alles
jetzt dreckig macht es nicht das thema
überhaupt nicht stimmt hauptsache es
schmeckt
[Musik]
das wird man hören lauter vergleich in
den honig der wirklich schön klar das
erste was du merkst dass ganz so
lieblich machen dass ich habe auch nicht
gespart mit granatapfel kern ich dachte
das ist genau richtig so richtig so sehr
gut zu schmecken wir sehen uns gleich
wenn alles aufgegessen ist doch schonmal
aufgegessen dass ein erstes gutes
zeichen ja vielleicht weißt du auch noch
nicht unmöglich sein nein nein also ich
habe vorher schon gesagt ich hab keinen
bock gesessen wäre das habe ich auch
gericht gekommen wo ich gedacht habe die
kriegt hat mithin oder die ich mir
zutraue sich trauen sehr viel zu aber es
war genial hätte jetzt gesagt hätte ich
auch so ins restaurant gehen können und
das ist für mich nur durch seine
durchdachte sache also ich hätte selbst
zu bewertet hätte ich im restaurant
gegessen schafskäse und hast dieses brot
was einfach das finde wolfe gewesen und
zugleich außen diese kruste richtig
knackig also hast du mich von der sockel
jetzt musst du den ganzen mit vielen
lieben dank erstmal muss ich dem ganzen
ort note verpasst von 0 bis 10 von 0 bis
10 ok ich würde ihn tatsächlich eine art
würde ich mit 903 geben
903 von dir ist glaub ich schon richtig
gut mit ja selbst ganz er ich weiß dass
du nicht mit guten noten und förster ist
allerdings sehr geehrt und ich
verspreche dir gibt mindestens genauso
vielen wir über mittag ich will hoffen
und das ist auch wieder reinkommen das
wirklich so ich muss bei manchen und
steht nun auch in meiner heimatstadt
guckst du musst dich die straße wechseln
weil mich bestimmt ihr habt besitzt
davon von lokalitäten nicht mehr sehen
wollen diese dreht ich sauer darauf dass
es so weitergehen dass nach köln kommen
kann gerade bei einfachen mitteln das
hier ist eine ansage wir haben ja einen
rib eye steak us-rapper und dieses tag
450 gramm vielleicht teilen wir uns das
dann prognosen keine sorgen machen aber
dazu habe ich ein bisschen französische
mutter aber schneiders und zwei schöne
scheiben dann habe ich hier rosmarin und
thymian aber nicht irgendeinen sondern
er hat so eine leichte zitrone ist auch
wo man sieht auch besonders aus ist es
wahr ist bio deshalb bin ich sehr
gespannt wie der sich auch das aroma des
fleischs auswirkt packen uns unser state
montag mit
das geben wir das gleich in street
becken und dann müssen wir einfach nur
noch abwarten das ist eine perfekten
zeitpunkt hat uns auf den grill zu legen
so zeit für bratkartoffeln aber nicht
irgendwie sondern rheinische knusprigen
bratkartoffeln wir haben hier
griebenschmalz den machen wir erstmal zu
beginn nach ordentlichen schicht
reicht's nächstes unsere charlotte die
schneiden wir in schöne töne regeln und
jetzt unsere kartoffeln hier habe ich
gewählt nachdem ich sie gekauft habe für
20 minuten und schneiden wir jetzt in
schöne gleichmäßig dicke scheiben wenn
unsere griebenschmalz ausgelassen ist
können wir auch unsere bratkartoffeln
schon reinpacken bemerkt sondern es ist
ja keine massenabfertigung sondern jede
bratkartoffeln mit liebe behandelt werde
jetzt von der ersten seite anbraten das
dauert auch seine zeit kümmere ich mich
um den speck wären wir so ein mageres
abgehangenes stück speck den schneide
ich einfach mal den relativ grobe würfel
weil die natürlich auch nochmal aus
lassen die haut zehn minuten vorbei und
so sieht die andere seite
nachzulesen
und jetzt fühlen wir noch die
zwischenräume mit unseren speckwürfeln
die auch nochmal natürlich bisschen was
auslassen nochmal geschmack da reingeben
bei fünf bis zehn minuten später und die
gegenseite
jetzt bleibt uns nicht mehr viel zu tun
als das ganze zu klippen
ein wenig salz
und reich ist fertig gegart und wir
gucken uns das ganze mal an und seht ihr
was dafür setzt sich darin bewegen in
dieser tüte das ist wirklich nicht
normal also das ist ganz ganz kraft und
man muss natürlich wissen dass fleisch
also das beispiel wenn jetzt noch kein
schönheitspreis ist es aber perfekt
gegart an jedem punkt ein wenig futter
schweiz und jetzt kommt der große moment
[Musik]
und wichtig ist wir wollen kontakt
deshalb lege ich jetzt wagen einfach ein
gewichtung auf
wir blicken
das ist kein geld da
[Musik]
ein feuerwerk der röstaromen glaub ich
das ist krass wo es eben auf dem grill
gesehen habt also so eine rüstung siehst
du selten also auch in der küche haben
die meisten leute einfach nicht so viel
zeit liegt so viel liebe in ein stück zu
stecken wir aber
gerade bei so einem stück vielleicht
sollte man das aber tun und ich mache
jetzt einfach etwas schon einmal den
mittel schnitt und die zuschauer sehen
es zuerst
guck mal total dass ich muss eigentlich
habe mega angst weil bei steak wurde es
sehr oft enttäuscht auch ein guter
auslöser nicht enttäuscht aber zuwider
warte ja bei dem schon jetzt mal
schon hat die leute hört einfach
besonders schön sagen der kartoffel
eigentlich meine angst bleibt durch den
von moni damals im kopf bewahrt dabei
ist zwar nicht mal so schön zurheide
zusammen aber auch so ein bisschen
ist ja auch der charlotte ist
kannst du dieser wirtshaus gestein das
ist ganz klar dass du sie dir typische
das ist auch dieses rauch von dem speck
mit drin machte mir so viel eigentlich
wir sehen uns vielleicht wieder den bau
dieses statement wir putzen die
kartoffeln weg mit recht so hier stehen
schon die nächsten vorbereitung nicht
für meinen video sondern für das vom
holle das ist wenn es online ist unten
verlinkt ansonsten kommt es die tage auf
dem kanal muss ich bin gespannt wie es
ihr geschmeckt for media wächst muss
sagen bei bratkartoffeln ist einer
leibspeise das habe ich mir von dir
gewünscht bin ich selber von
bratkartoffeln sehr überzeugt mache ich
aber ganz anders bei den traktoren
glaube ich wenn man sie jetzt zu kaufen
und das habe ich wirklich so nathan und
nie gesagt glaube ich kann man sie nicht
besser machen weil man sie in der
abfahrt machen das heißt wirklich so
noch nicht gesagt und da habe ich
etliche male ist mir egal ich auch
abgeraten videoausgabe ich mit kollegen
gemacht hat das habe ich echt schlecht
bewertet wäre es nicht so dass ich das
jetzt bei den sack würde ich 97 punkte
vielleicht kommen wir doch noch bessere
leute die beraterin der hut sein effekt
glaub ich handwerklich auch wieder
perfekt hast du von außen einfach die
kruste und diese zahl teilt glaube nicht
besser ich würde aber soll das auf ihr
mir selber das selber klar gemacht was
zählt was der punkt ist die us beef oder
ein anderes ich glaube ein anderes der
umstellung ist fleischgeschmack in sich
gehabt ja ja so dass habe ihn ja klar
das wusste nicht dass wir auch der
profis sagen es dagegen so ein bisschen
besser zahlt alles perfekt würde ich
acht von zehn geben weil der
fleischgeschmack vielleicht einfach da
kannst du ja kein einfaches nein nein
aber ja also ich würde es wirklich nicht
beklagen also das sind sehr westen und
näher und es abendessen probiere ich
etwas aus deshalb habe ich sorge dass
hier alles einbricht der gesamte erfolgt
wieder zusammen fällt aber ich werde
versuchen ich gebe mein bestes los geht
es mit dem abend warum ist das so schwer
ist hast du besonders was ich heute
abend machen die zutaten sehen
eigentlich relativ simpel aus aber
probiere on your eyes zu machen das ist
mir das kennt das haben wir gesucht als
wir mitte tokio an ein bett aus reis
gebratener reis relativ simpel und
obendrauf ein perfektes japanisches
annett welches wirklich schwer zu machen
ist ich war wirklich schaffen werde mein
bestes gebe als allererstes 1 butter in
die pfanne und heute weil wir panisch
kommen das ganze natürlich treppchen
muss nämlich jetzt lernen wie ich die
hände später sehr entscheidende move wo
ich das omelett anwenden muss sich auch
mit schnäppchen machen besser ich
gewöhnlich schon vergeben dann jetzt
unser chicken hinein
das hähnchen kommt in den beratenden
reicht etwa die untere hälfte darstellt
ich fühle mich wirklich ein bisschen wie
vor so einer großen prüfung er wirklich
weil ich meine ich mache es hat er sich
doch wir machen das heute und wenn es
funktioniert normal happy wenn das ganze
so halten wie es gekocht ist kommt auch
schon unsere zwiebel dazu normalerweise
betriebe die kochen jetzt bis sie glasig
ist chef vom nist cuisine g7 sind
klassik dann gehen wir unseren weiß
daran reduzierte montierte geflügelbrühe
davon gebe ich jetzt ein bisschen was
dazu
wir brauchen aber auf jeden fall gleich
am ende noch was ganz zu stoppen der
verteidigung zurück und gegeben ketchup
land
und für die farbe noch ein bisschen
größer ist als ob es gibt eigentlich
spezielle form herumgereist aber wir
machen das jetzt einfach so zu einer
tiefen schüssel und jetzt auch nur eine
portion das heißt denn es funktioniert
und hat glücklich first drive
funktioniert so zwei scheiben
eingeschlagen wir die eier verquirlen
sommer dann gehen wir dazu ein esslöffel
sahne und ein esslöffel milch diesem
zeitpunkt nicht mehr zu stark mixen weil
man kann sich vorstellen was wird aus
adelschlag sein klickt er durch eine
hellere farbe und das schütten wir jetzt
eben durch sie hindurch
nach in die pfanne heiß und geben eine
geschmacksneutrale in der renten- und
nicht gerade wenig
es würden leicht ist geschafft dass
japan diese stoffe bewusstes schaffen
ich hab das schon und wir geben das 1 1
und jetzt
darfst kurz stehen
das lied schon eigentlich ganz gut aus
wenn ich bis jetzt ist muss aber noch
weiter durchgehen jetzt
ziehen wir es hier an den seiten
komplett einmal ab
ich habe das einmal hilft vor
gegenseite klappten mir entgegen und
jetzt
welche richtung
es für dich
was mach ich jetzt
ok ok ok bis halbwegs in ordnung glaube
ich dass wir jetzt hier gemacht haben
neben den deckel jetzt legen wir das
ganze einmal drüber was geht von selbst
auf aber
sind nicht verkehrt als gültiger erster
versuch also ich würde
sie nicht perfekt aber ich bin höchst
das wird sehr intensiv ist endlich damit
übertreiben und hier haben wir einen
ersten praxisversuch also
schönheitspreis gewinnen ich nicht bin
aber ganz froh dafür wie die konsistenz
aussieht was sagst du optisch geht nur
dein feedback also optisch natürlich die
das besser aber ich bin jetzt gerade zu
hause auch gewohnt nicht immer so zehn
von zehn von der optik also ich kann
auch einfach mit guten geschmack leben
da muss den perfekt aussehen dann hoffe
ich dass wir den haben ich muss jetzt
einfach mal direkt mit ihr mit probiere
gerne ein bisschen um das bischen reis
zusammen
wie gerne hätte im moment wenn du diesen
moment haben möchte
der kommt mir aber die augen dabei
belegt
ok so ganz cool mit der sauce bei
skeptisch weil sie nicht so jetzt auch
wieder mega mit sich aus aber die soße
ist ganz entscheidend bei dem gericht
hat sie bisher spaß gemacht es war mir
egal es war wirklich mir ich muss sagen
irgendwo anstrengend weil wir verbringen
wirklich viel zeit miteinander und ich
dachte dass wir ein bisschen
komprimierte aber es war wirklich ein
ganzer tag zu wurden zusammen gewertet
gechillt hat wo und jetzt ist nur noch
immer die kamera sequenzen aber du hast
jetzt überzeugt ist was sagst du zu dem
gesicht also optisch ist es nicht erste
sahne optisch wird wir denken nicht
überreden aber ich versuche mich auch
mal rein zu versetzen dass das gericht
so irgendwie herauszuschmecken ich habe
eben zuwachs auch noch mal gesagt ist ja
viel butter drin ich arbeite gerne mit
gott aber man merkt einen schönen
muttertag steht das gab es schon mal
lieblich macht und das ist negativ
gewesen so hasst die butter nur dazu den
ketchup dennoch dabei wer hat das
irgendwo grund gemacht leichte säure ich
denk mal durch die wirtschafts- oder wie
würdest du das gefühl hast du hast alles
ist einfach ein ganz rundes ding so
inbegriff von vollmundigkeit wir alles
in den gerichten und ich würde ihnen
tatsächlich auch nur 914 geben im
wunderland oder dämlichkeit gerät
komplett gericht heute lassen wir die
optik außenpolitiker annehme habe ich
ganz raus gesagt okay ich habe ganz raus
was ist bei bewertung des man meistens
nicht eigentlich will ich ja mein
letzter gewertet weil es ja auch in
begriffen mit den eher unbewusst
vielleicht welche neun von zehn gehen
war einfach wie gesagt so das
komplettpaket du hast alles gab
vollmundig so du bist einfach zu viel
gewesen vorwärts also man muss wirklich
sagen ich habe immer gesagt also
hereinspaziert ist dass er mir immer
ehrlich feedback geben sollte ich fand
auch alles heute wirklich super lecker
deshalb gehe ich auch mit aber ich bin
auch super stolz als bewährt hat für
solche anlagen hat daniels es war es war
es war ein spaß und ja dann kommt auf
jeden fall das video auf höhe des kanal
mit mir bis zum nächsten mal was gutes